hi everybody um so
in this recording i will go uh
over a few central concepts
in uh in synthesizing uh control
protocols for hybrid
cyber physical systems uh so these
will typically be hierarchical control
protocols and
uh i will not try to get into every
little detail but
i will try to go over some some of the
main concepts that pop up
in this context and hierarchy control
protocols
are relatively universal
in in a lot of applications in a lot of
engineering applications
definitely in cyber physical systems and
also autonomous systems
and in the background i will be using
this
autonomous navigation type example as a
running example
so um i'm i'm planning to give you
some of the ideas behind the solutions
that had been proposed
over the last couple of decades for a
synthesis problem as
shown on this first slide so this is
what we will be able to
we will talk about um so it's just a
sample problem
and uh it is given it is going to be
stated whenever
it makes sense i will i will try to
relate it to autonomous navigation
autonomous driving and other autonomous
navigation examples
so uh it is it is a
problem there a couple of things are
given uh so we
have a system we have we may be trying
to control
a an autonomous car or some other system
and the model is going to have a couple
of elements to it
it may includes what i'm going to call
a dynamical system model that is going
to have both continuous and discrete
evolution and
we will look into this a little bit more
carefully
we will have certain control authority
in the system but
there will be limitations to that and
very often we will not have a perfect
model so we will have
modeling uncertainties and disturbances
from outside
and so that's going to be the model site
and the specification site essentially
what we want the system to be able to
achieve
the high level requirements and goals
will be given in some form
and uh the requirements might be coming
for example in this application from the
from a driver's handbook we might have a
prior mission in mind that
is given over a course map or some other
representation of the environment
and the system is going to be operating
in a dynamic environment that is going
to be
affecting whether the system can stay
safe
whether it can satisfy the requirements
achieve its goals
and therefore we will need to narrow
down in what kind of an environment the
system might operate
and the specifications will include also
knowledge about the assumptions that we
can make
the a priori unknown we don't know what
exactly how the
environment is going to be evolving but
we will making assumptions on how it
may be evolved but how it may evolve and
again
this is going to be a dynamic
environment things will change and the
system will need to react to it
and the goal is to some extent
if possible fully automate the synthesis
of a control protocol
and we will see what protocol refers to
in this context
that is going to manage the behavior of
the system it's going to tell this
car how to navigate and it will need to
react to the changes
in the external environments
and we want to be able to have an
argument uh
obviously consistent with what we have
been given we want to be
able to give a proof that the system is
going to
if we follow the the synthesis procedure
that we will describe in these notes
if you follow that the outcome is going
to be
provenly correct with respect to the
requirements obviously the set
in the problem statement so this is the
rough problem
and uh
one it is not uh it is not
mathematically stated yet
but also even at this level we can see
that uh this
problem does not necessarily live in the
in in the comfort zone of a single field
there are
things that resemble we might want to go
to
formal methods uh but then also these
elements that hey we have we might have
continued state variables
modeling uncertainties disturbance etc
that also resembles that
uh it might as well be connected to
controls
so um that is essentially the
the difficulty the problem does not
belong to to one field
and therefore we will need to make
connections between ideas
uh from multiple fields and in this in
this set of notes
these connections will be roughly made
between
controls and formal methods so for a con
controls person then we would need to
introduce
a language in which we might we may be
able to specify
uh the properties that we care about but
then
the models that we are familiar with
more in on the formal method site
by themselves will may not be uh
sufficient
and we might need to uh evolve them a
little bit as well so
a couple of slides now we'll touch on
these uh
for those of you who know what these
things are obviously
it is going to be and not new uh but uh
let's
briefly mention uh first of all we need
a specification language in which we can
we can state the properties that we care
um the the the requirements in for
example the driver's handbook
a autonomous system might have to follow
uh
are not uh properties that a controls
person
uh usually deals with uh they are higher
level they are
much richer than a typical control
system is
required to behave and um so this is one
of the revolutions that's
the formal methods and theoretical
computer science made
probably decades ago and much later on
in the context of cyber physical systems
or hybrid systems or connections to
controls
had formal specification languages
that their utility had been
realized so i am going to refer to very
vaguely temporal logic i'm not saying
i'm not telling what version of temporal
logic that we will be dealing with but
temporal logic is essentially going to
give
the working ground for us to obviously
reason about infinite sequences of
states
of the system and the state in this
context is everything that we care about
everything that can influence the
correctness or the safety of the
of the underlying system it could be the
uh
the properties at each instant of the
system that we are controlling but also
we will take a snapshot of the
entire environment that is relevant
and that snapshot is going to constitute
the value of the state at that
instant and and obviously there are many
different dialects
or versions of temporal logic and in
this talk i'm not going to get into any
of them i'm
hoping to get to to touch on
um different versions of tempo logic and
how they might be utilized in the
context of cyber physical systems
in the other recordings uh today
mainly linear temporal logic but very
quickly we will actually narrow down
from linear temporal logic
even further and uh
and obviously we will use this these
languages to specify safe allowable
required or desired behavior of the
system and the environment itself
and so in the context of a
little navigation example
we might use these these languages to
write
down that we don't want our system to
collide with anything
we may want to uh obey the speed limits
uh we might want to specify which which
lanes the
vehicle can be in if it is blocked what
might be the options
uh what are the requirements or
restrictions that
that intersections stop lines etc
and also the goals of the system might
be specified as
to reaching some point or
uh reacting to something in such a way
that if something happens then
eventually we want the system to be able
to
uh go and do something useful and the
environment assumptions
uh in this context for example that the
intersection
the vehicle might arrive at is going to
at some point be empty if
the intersection never clears uh we
obviously will not be able to find a
control protocol that would
ever get the vehicle through that
intersection and any reasonable
intersection will at some point clear
uh and uh we should we should be able to
specify that in the statement of the
problem so that we have us
we end up having a solo problem
synthesis problem if
if there is a there is a protocol that
can achieve the requirements that we
have
and the list goes on uh we might uh list
a couple of things about the sensing
range of the vehicle
and its ability to detect uh the
obstacles
uh we might know that the obstacles
around the vehicles
are other physical objects that can not
for example transport themselves or they
cannot
disappear at some point and then pop up
instantly at some
far uh distant point
we should be able to specify these
things and uh the work
in this area um has been util
using uh variants of temporal logic for
this purpose
okay so this is and then obviously these
things are not
uh specific for only one application um
autonomous navigation is one this is
another multi a multi-vehicle
uh air vehicle in this case um
multi-air vehicle navigation scenario
and it is it had been integrated into a
uh
into a user interface through which one
can specify
uh what missions multiple air vehicles
may need to deliver for different
purposes
and in this case what coverage area in
what sequence the goals
need to be achieved the coordination
between multiple vehicles so that they
don't arrive at the same point at the
same time
etc can be specified using temporal
logic
okay so that is one point the other
point is that
formal method to say the bread and
butter of system models
it would be fair to say that in formal
methods more finite state
representations of the systems
and uh we often encounter
evolution of systems that main for which
merely finite state evolution discrete
jumps may not be
suitable or sufficient and um
in the intersection of what controls had
been studying
more based on differential equations or
difference equations and finite state
representation on the other side
the notion of hybrid systems had emerged
and
it essentially mixes these two things
and in this slide i have an
extremely simple representation of the
hybrid system model
it is a tuple where we specify uh
the states both the discrete and
continuous states and
specify how the continuous state evolves
and how the discrete state may evolve
and in this one very simple
representation essential discreteness of
the system is coming from that the
continuous state space
had been uh is partitioned into
regions uh and in each region the the
underlying differential equation is
different
so the system follows a continuous
uh a differential equation or a
difference equation
for the evolution of its continuous
state and whenever it actually changes
from one region to another where
the labels of these regions may uh
represent the discrete
states um uh it changes its
it's it's the differential equation or
difference equation it follows
um i'm not going to get into details so
that is essentially the main picture for
each region you
you you may have a different
um let's say x is the continuous space
state a different difference
a different differential equation in
this region it may follow
f1 at the vector field and in this
region it may follow
some other differential equation
where the vector field is different and
and it can be much richer than this
uh this description
uh but for the purpose of today's uh
notions
uh it won't be too relevant
so um i'm gonna go with this uh hybrid
system model for now
essentially it is uh it is switching
between uh different
um uh between different vector fields
over the state space continuous state
space okay
with that um
in what ways do hybrid system models
arise so
a couple of comments could be made about
that and
and not all of these will become
relevant for our purposes but
i thought it might be it might be useful
to remember
so one way to that may appear is that we
might have actually a fully continuous
state space but the system dynamics
might be
too complicated to for analysis or
design purposes
and we might use
piecewise fine representations it does
not have to be fine but essentially over
different parts of this continuous state
space
we we might choose in a localized manner
to have
simpler dynamical system models and then
we patch them
and the switching essentially induces
the hybrid nature of the system
we might have uh impact from outside uh
in in the form of this discontinuous
jumps in the dynamics for example in
this bouncing ball
example the ball is under the influence
of essentially the gravity
uh but every time it touches the ground
it it has a
it has a jump and it in
in its speed uh and that that
induces the the hybridness of the
dynamics
the the hybridness might come
essentially
the hybridness might come from the way
that we actually control
how we observe the system and then how
we choose to control it
and it is referred to as a quantized
control uh
we may choose not to see all the details
of the continuous state space but we
might
want to look uh look at this through the
through the lens of
a quantization of the underlying state
space or the control space
we may have logic based switching uh
and a canonical exam a good example for
this is this
collision avoidance uh two aircraft
flying in certain ways but
if they get close to each other uh there
is an underlying protocol that
uh abruptly changes the evolution of
these two systems
so that they avoid each other and
another way of
which is going to be very relevant for
us is that we may have a
continuous or some sort of continuous
state
evolution but the specifications may be
discrete
and and this discrete specifications is
in the in in quotes
uh it is essentially referring to
roughly that
uh there are specifications
uh which for which uh we have
means to analyze or design
if the rest of the system was discrete
for example temporal logic
specifications
given over a finite state model that
we are we know or we are more confident
how we can analyze such systems
and uh and uh designed for such systems
but now if one side has continuous
evolution and we have temporal logic
like specifications
neither field has the right uh right
tools for it
so what i'm trying to emphasize here is
that there is a mismatch between the
the representation of the different
parts of the system
and that gives that gives uh
that gives the results in uh
in in notions of hybridness in the in
the underlying representations
okay so with that uh let me just
remind you what the problem that we will
be studying in this
in in this recording i it is just a
slight repeated but
now instead of having this vehicle
picture we will have a
uh sort of a hybrid system model
that represents the system and then
specifications we will use versions of
temporal logic too
to represent the specifications so with
that
we can actually now we can we can try to
develop
algorithms because uh these these two
elements will help us to write down
mathematical problems that we can study
and before doing that um
let me just discuss a tiny bit on
the some of the different approaches for
the analysis and verification
verification and synthesis for hybrid
system mouse
so uh and essentially
um one thing that we need to realize is
that
uh for systems that have continued state
spaces
exhaustive search is not going to be
possible
and so we cannot directly apply
the ideas from formal methods on the
other hand
uh the several approaches that we have
seen over the last couple of decades
are essentially thinking hey i mean i
know i have the tools
for analyzing finite state models
let me make a finite state system out of
this
otherwise continuous space
state space representation so
they rely on constructing finite state
approximations of the underlying
dynamics and then applied to tools that
that are that can be used for finite
state models
uh so i would say that hey i have a
problem outside the domain of formal
methods let me do something
pull it into the formal methods domain
and then see what i can do there
and then obviously we will wrap things
around it and um
so we while doing finding these
approximations
we need to pay attention to that as we
approximate the systems we do not lose
the meaning of the properties or
if we have a property over one
representation of the model but we
analyze or design with another
representation of the model the
specifications given on this side
should be able to uh unambiguously
interpretable on the other side
and then approximations should have
certain properties
for uh yielding um meaningful
uh results so we'll look into that as
well so this is one approach
essentially this is hey i'm a formal
methods person give me a hybrid system
model
i'm going to pull it to my site i will i
will crunch it
using my tools the other side is the
controls
mostly controls controls approach i
would say
i have tools to deal with infinite state
continuous state
problems or systems how can i pull this
hybrid system question
to my side and then try to crunch it
with my tools
and i am going to i'm going to summarize
it
under this what i'm calling deductive
techniques essentially it takes the
underlying system
since it cannot go and enumerate or
represent every single state of the
system or
people every possible evolution of the
system
we would have to have an alternative
approach which is
uh try to construct so-called algebraic
certificates so try to find a function
that satisfies certain properties and
after that
it actually witnesses the the
satisfaction of the property that we
care
and lyapunov functions barrier
certificates are
examples of these things uh if there's a
controls version of it
obviously various ways of approximating
so-called value functions will be
will be relevant and then uh the
underlying hybrid dynamics usually have
these discrete jumps
so we will deal with we will try to deal
with that in some
in some way um um essentially
uh extending the notions of these
algebraic proof certificates
to deal with the existence of different
regimes or different regions in the
state space that
in which the system behaves differently
a
third approach is essentially uh trying
to somehow
just between these two uh not
necessarily enumerate one by one
all possible futures of the system but
somehow explicitly construct the set of
reachable states
starting from some initial state somehow
represent this initial the set of
initial states
find these tubes or at each
instant where this system might end up
try to
represent these set of states and
propagate them
either forward in time or backward in
time and then see
whether they intersect with the with
some unsafe sets
or whether they ever have intersections
with uh
with some desirable points that you
might want to reach etcetera so the
point is that
explicit representation of the set of
states in which the system might end up
being
so i'm not going to touch on this one
too much today
in this recording i will go uh in this
direction
in the first one and if time allows i am
planning to have
another recording uh on these deductive
techniques
okay with that let's see what the next
slide is okay so as i said
if the approach is going to be somehow
make a finite state approximation out of
the given hybrid dynamics
for the discrete pattern we don't have
to do much but for the continuous state
evolution we somehow need to
make it finite and then we will need to
have certain
properties in this finite approximation
and
roughly i'm going to call these things
as under and over approximations of the
underlying
system so we have a hybrid system model
um and um just this picture i'm going to
carry around and then we are given a
finite
transition system uh for uh for
simplicity i'm not having a an extra
control input in this in this in these
representations
so you might consider that somebody
already gave you a controller the
extensions are
are not too complicated it is just going
to be it's not
i cannot fit them into one slide so
let's just limit this
so we will we will try to make a
connection between these two
representations
and the first thing is uh essentially
the
states of the finite transition system
will be these
qis and we will associate a
each qi with one um
one region in a partition let's say we
already partitioned the underlying
continuous state space and we will touch
on
how we might partition but let's say for
now we have a partition and
for each cell in this continuous state
space we'll associate a discrete state
qi
and then this t essentially is a map
from the
discrete state to the the top sub subset
of
x to which the q i corresponds to
t tq1 is this region for example t q2 is
this region
so we will have that uh
then we will go and
so we will now ask once we have these
uh these regions under discrete states
we will try to define or choose the
transitions between the states
in such a way that we can have the
desired
relation between this hybrid system h
and the finite transition system q
sorry ts and here's here's
one statement of it we will call the ts
and under approximation of h if these
following two statements hold
essentially let's try to read it
so given q and q prime the two discrete
states they are not the same
if they are the same we will treat them
differently
if there is a transition
from q to q prime in in the finite
transition system then let's pick two
states at two regions here
let's say one region is this this is q
and this is q prime
then for all initial states in q
all of all initial states all points in
this
there exists some time such that
the system ends up within at the end of
that time period
tau the system ends up somewhere
in this region in the region that
corresponds to q prime
and for all times between the initial
time and the star
the end of the time horizon we have to
stay
in the union of these two all right
so essentially for all states in the
initial
in the region that corresponds to the uh
transition discrete transition
we are emanating the discrete transition
from q
for all initial states in the region
that corresponds to q
we should be able to find a an evolution
up to some time tau that ends up in the
region that corresponds to q prime
and for all those times we want to stay
inside this region
so then if we have that property we will
have a transition from q to q prime
and there is a possibility for a self
transition
and that's going to happen if the region
that corresponds to q is positively
invariant that is
in all future times we essentially don't
leave that region
so if we
restrict the transition system ts to
have transitions that
are characterized by by these conditions
then the resulting ts is going to be an
under approximation of the hybrid system
so that also is going to mean that every
discrete trajectory
in ts can be implemented by
h no matter where you start here
there is some future that's going to
take you somewhere in this region
that corresponds to q prime it does not
matter you start here
there's something that takes you there
so if we had those properties that we
will call it as an under approximation
and the over approximation is
uh the flip side of the coin is
essentially uh
we will include a trans a transition
discrete transition
for example q q prime and q double prime
uh so we have here two
continuous trajectories starting from
two different initial conditions that in
from in the region that corresponds to q
one and that ends up in the region for q
prime
and the other one ends up in the region
q double prime
in this case in the transition system
for over approximation we will include
both
q q prime and q double prime
all right so over approximation looks
into a possibility is it possible for me
to find
an initial condition in this region that
would take me to q prime
yes it is possible here is it possible
to
go to collect your double prime yes this
is possible there is another another
initial condition that's going to take
you there
but they they may be different initial
conditions they may end up in different
regions and we will include
all these transitions so this is a we
are talking about the possibility
um it does not say that if i start
here i will be able to go to q prime
it just says that hey it is possible
that if you started from some
appropriate point in this region then
you will end up in q double prime so
that's the difference
whereas in under approximation if you
start from in
from this region no matter which initial
condition you pick you will end up
in q prime okay so under and over
approximations
and um and for
verification and synthesis purposes both
could be useful
um uh useful means and
we will today for synthesis purposes we
will mostly look into other
approximations so now
we have a lot of tools let's look at
what a solution looks like
uh finally this notion of hierarchical
control structure
so it is going to look something like
this and
i am going to hide this part
and the reason is that um that is
too low level for us to deal with there
are lots of
zillions of tools in controls to make
sure that
these systems at very low level behave
properly or if i give a short trajectory
they will be able to follow that they
will be able to go to some point etc so
we will not
deal with that we will we will look into
this hierarchical structure here
um okay so let me see
um i need to get rid of these boxes
okay they are gone um
okay
not sure how to get rid of these uh
things uh let's try one more time
maybe this time they are gone okay there
you go
so uh as i said we will focus on
on this or on the hierarchy but that we
see here three levels the names do not
matter the point is that
uh there are there are multiple
functionalities that
we need to synthesize separately but
uh in coordination with each other
and the problem uh cannot be solved in
one shot the synthesis problem that we
have
instead what we will be doing is uh we
will be having these
layers i'm showing three and each layer
is going to be working with
a different um part
view of the specifications so the lowest
level is going to work with the
constraints on the continuous state
space
and maybe the inputs and it's going to
approp uh
correspondingly it is going to work with
uh the
the the the some difference equations
and uh in this
i'm in this talk and i'm referring to
the evolution of time
interchangeably with continuous time and
uh discrete time
and these slides for
for cleanness but in all implementations
i will be actually looking into discrete
time evolution so if i go back and forth
this is just
so pictorially here uh but when it comes
to implementations or algorithms
we will be directly working with
continuous sorry discrete time evolution
and uh and extensions to continuous time
are possible uh it just makes it uh
uglier and some technicalities might
arise
but the main ideas will mostly carry
over
okay so we will chop the specifications
into different views
and we will pick uh represent models
that
abstractions that that are appropriate
for that
view of the specifications at the lowest
level constraints on the continuous
space
and we will be working with uh discrete
uh
space models sorry continue space models
that middle level might be the
short horizon specifications and in this
case we might uh
jump into uh some discrete evolution and
and just it's gonna go on like that and
depending on what specifications you end
up at in
each level and what models that you use
obviously the resulting
problems that we have to solve of course
will correspond to that at the bottom
level we will be dealing with
constrained finite state optimal control
problems
typically we will
choose to reason about the dynamic
environment
around us uh at this discrete level
that has uh some
uh implicit assumption on that uh we
look at the evolution of the dynamic
environment around us
uh the other cars uh the
the conditions on the road the traffic
lights etc
are only at these discrete time
instances
at which we see the system uh at these
states of the
uh discrete model and then as we go
higher up
and and then we will end up solving uh
two-player turn-based
uh games and i will uh
briefly touch on that and i know you
will have seen
uh earlier this week uh more detailed
exposure to such
problems and then long horizon
specifications i say
at the high level and nothing is
actually set on stone uh these are just
some little examples of how
we might want to chop things off in a
hierarchical manner
and in this setting uh we might think it
is as that if this is a navigation
the highest level might be choosing the
highways the streets that we are
we might follow and then once we have it
the
middle level might look into hey is the
intersection empty
can i follow this throat shall i change
my lane because it might be blocked etc
so that level of
reactive reasoning against the
environment and the low level once we
decide okay i'm following this lane
so let me find a continuous trajectory
okay i need to change my lane
let me find the trajectory that's going
to do that for me for for very
very short alright so
uh everybody can decompose any given
heart problem in
any way that they want right the key is
not that the key
is essentially doing it in such a way
that
we have conditions between
uh between these layers
conditions between these layers such
that there's a consistency between the
layers
and this is where the abstractions the
under approximation or over
approximation in this case we will start
from the bottom
level and we will go higher and we will
try to have under approximations
so that when we put these pieces
together
everything is going to be consistent
with each other if this top
level issues a directive right
then the middle level will be able to
implement that and similarly if the
reactive controller says something
there's going to be a continuous
trajectory for
that we can pick and implement and now
it is going to
um accomplish whatever uh goal
intermediate goal is mid-level actually
set for us
and and and this description essentially
takes care of a couple of things
people often uh call these things
correct by construction it's just that
we have we will have constructed the
models and depict the specifications in
such a way that
once we solve the problems in each layer
because there's consistency between
models and because the specifications
then put together they actually
guarantee that the overall constraints
or requirements that we have will be
satisfied
by construction of these elements we
will have a guarantee that this
overall uh overall picture is going to
be yielding
a solution to the problem that we want
to solve at the beginning
so that is going to be the correct way
construction part
so what i'm going to do is now look into
some of these layers a little bit
closely and uh and and then and then
we'll see what happens
so i'm going to start with the middle
levels so
uh and it is going to essentially rely
on
what is out there for reactive synthesis
or
uh we looked into game solving in the
previous
we will have looked into game solving in
the previous lectures it's going to rely
on that
and it is it is not a coincidence uh so
this is this is
um uh from where i have been
over the last decade or so the
historical evolution
is that hey something is happening in
reactive synthesis
right and these problems that we are
trying to solve
have resemblance so how can we morph the
problems
in such a way that we can we can
leverage what is happening on the
theoretical computer science side
and we can try to build uh solutions for
bigger problems that we cannot solve
otherwise
so the intention was how can we leverage
reactive
synthesis and for this obviously we will
need a finite transition system
and that is going to be that the model
that we will have for the middle layer
and then i'm going to talk about
one way of obtaining this so there will
be some controlled variables
the specification will be that hey i
have these environment assumptions
whenever environment does not does
whenever environment is constrained in
certain way i want my system to satisfy
the specifications
these we can refer to them as stream
guarantee specifications
and this is
there is no doubt that specifications in
the form of assume assumptions and
guarantees are the right
uh right way of looking into
problems in cyber physical systems or
autonomous systems because all of them
are actually
operating in ones that they cannot
control
and the environment is represented by uh
by a variable e
so what's going to happen is that the
reactive controller is going to observe
what the environment has been doing
including the current step that we are
at
and it is going to know what has been
happening in its own control states and
it's going to pick the
the next uh controlled
variables in certain way that we satisfy
the specifications that we have
so this was uh this can be formed
formulated as a turn-based
game interactable in general but much
more for giving
complexity for certain fragments of
temporal logic for example the gr1
specifications
in the form of again it is an assumption
and guarantee
and the pieces are we can say initially
we can talk about initializations
we can talk about invariants or some
mild uh
mild safety formulas and uh we can also
talk about
uh the uh the liveness or fairness and
uh goals for environment uh
we can we can say that the environment
does certain things
infinitely often in the future so we
know that it's going to come to certain
places
and then given that whether we can
actually get our system
infinitely often to certain other places
so syntactically uh restricted obviously
but um the world is the the name of the
game is not only expressiveness
for all these things that we discuss you
can find more complicated hybrid system
models you can find more complicated
specifications but the name of the game
is not only expressions it is
whether we can we can have a little bit
more forgiving complexes so that we can
solve
some problems that might have relevance
for reality
and gr1 specifications
as i see it have proven to be actually
hitting some useful sweet spots it
doesn't it does not cover everything
but it doesn't have to cover everything
it has fonts broad enough applications
where it can solve interesting problems
and the resulting strategy is going to
be essentially hey look at
how the environment evolves and pick the
next
the next move for the system
and if we look at it uh so
given a finite transition system we can
take this controller g we have
composed with n and we will be
satisfying the specifications that we
can interpret
at this layer
but as we have been saying we will have
continuous
dynamics under underlying continuous
dynamics
uh so uh we will we will have uh
system representations more general than
uh
finite state finite transition systems
or we may not even given finite
transition systems
so how are we going to connect these two
just the reality or physics of the
system is here
reactive synthesis offers to deal with
finite transition systems how are we
going to connect these two
and this is where the continuous
controller or the bottom layer in this
pictorial or cartoonish higher hierarchy
shortcut
essentially it is the layer between what
reactive synthesis can handle
and what the underlying reality is
and this is where a finite state
abstraction
uh procedure uh comes in where we will
know that the
resulting thing is going to be a
an under approximation we already looked
into what an
underapproximation means so essentially
we will start with the continuous state
space
we'll end up with a finite transition
system this is going to be an
under approximation of the given
of the given um of the given uh
underlying continuous or hybrid system
model
again partition the continuous state
space
and then associate a discrete state for
each
cell in the partition and then uh
we will decide what what transitions we
can assign
and let's look at this yellow to blue we
already discussed that we will include
that transition if for all initial
states in this one
there is a way for us to go to the blue
one and previously i looked into that
with no inputs
when there is inputs the resulting
problem turns out to be a
robust set to set to reachable the
problem and
uh so the dynamics let me just actually
step back and show you what the dynamics
look like so we have the continuous
state space
we have the control input this is the
input underlying
low level control input that we can pick
to
influence the evolution of x and we are
subject to some disturbances as well so
this w
we cannot control it can be i don't know
some some
roughness or slickeners on the road or
some vents etc might be coming and
affecting the underlying continuous
evolution
so the problem that we are trying to
solve is whether there exists a control
input u
and some finite horizon length t
it's the horizon length that we are
looking into such that for
all time instances up to that horizon
the state stays
in the intersection of some initial set
and some target set
initial sets this is just we are
focusing on whether this discrete
transition we can go from this region to
this region
with the right qualifiers so
there exists a control signal such that
we stay
in the union of this at the end of the
time horizon we are in the target set
and it qualifies our for all initial
conditions x0 for all initial conditions
here and for
all um for all low-level disturbances
so this is a problem and the dynamics
are given here this is a problem
which is extremely hard by itself uh
and uh
yes that's that's that's a true
statement it's extremely hard by itself
so we cannot hope to sow it for
all possible cases but research has
shown that if the underlying dynamics
are hybrids but the
within each mod within each region for
example you have
linear dynamics or a fine dynamics
and all the sets that you encounter this
set
this set this set this set all sets that
you may
you might encounter um in this
in the statement of the problem our
polytopic can represent it as
combinations of affine inequalities then
there is some hope
all right and there are lots of tools
out there
that look into different even within
this
general family different ways of
representing says different ways of
representing the underlying dynamics so
that
just we can scale these things up and
then
a little bit more research inside but
still we might do something
when the underlying dynamics are
polynomial and the
constraints are all the sets are uh
semi-algebraic they can be represented
as inequalities on polynomials
then we can actually start having some
upper and lower
above upper and lower approximations of
these
regions that sets we have to keep track
of and then
we may have some hope and some other
side of researches
looking into whether there are some
underlying properties of the dynamics
the dynamics might be
ugly in one representation they might be
they might be uh impenetrably nonlinear
that we cannot deal with
but if we can for example transform
these dynamics into some
other coordinate frame using the
so-called differential flatness of the
underlying system
then these point-to-point or
set-to-point reachability problems might
be
solvable to some extent much more
efficiently
but then uh this transformation might
bring some
potential errors that we might need to
deal with by again dwelling or shrinking
these sets that we care about
and uh so we might come be able to come
up but hey i i
i cannot answer this question but
if this target set was something larger
maybe i can guarantee that there is
something in that larger thing and then
you need to then
keep track of these this data that you
gather and
build an under approximation out of that
and it might introduce a possibility of
uh errors that you make hey i think this
this discrete transition is possible but
because of this uh
there's a there's some possibility that
at some point you might not be able to
make this transition so you need to
essentially bookkeep all these things
long story short
this is the problem that we need to
solve sorry this is the problem that we
need to solve
and we may be able to solve in some
cases and we might play lots of
uh games uh when things are
a little bit different uh let's see for
now that we can solve that problem then
we can put these things together again
this is this picture that we looked into
uh so what's gonna happen is essentially
by constructing the underlying
abstraction the right way
what we can guarantee is that for any
discrete run and this is coming
from uh this is coming from the fact
that
by construction the uh the abstraction
is under approximation
any discrete run that satisfies the
specification let's say this is the
sequence of discrete states that we
follow and it satisfies the
specification because
the reactive synthesis tool that i used
with the right abstraction etc
tells me that hey you need to follow
this uh
and it satisfies the specification then
there exists an admissible
control signal that generates a
trajectory over the continuous state
space
i labeled these regions as news but
actually we are now looking into
discontinuous
trajectory so if this if there is this
then by construction there is a control
signal that's going to drive the
continuous states it's continuous
uh part of the continuous uh states
as shown in this lower part and that
continuous implementation will also
satisfy the specification
so that is that uh and this is
essentially just
stating what i just said and then
it may not be possible right you just
you have this abstraction now
and it turns out that there is no
way of finding a reactive controller
that's going to give you a
what you like then there may be zillions
of reasons for this
one of which is that hey this problem is
actually not soluble but
then it may be that the abstraction that
you have is too coarse that you cannot
find
uh you cannot you did not include enough
possibilities in your abstraction to
to see to achieve what you wanted then
obviously
a bunch of abstraction refining
techniques essentially
versions of uh hacked versions of
counter example guided abstraction
refinement comes into play and say okay
look
from this i cannot tell you that you
will
necessarily end up in this but what i
can tell you is that
there is a there's a subset of this
initial set
from which you can go to this i don't
know what happens from this
from this part then instead of working
with
uh essential on e5 we say hey i am now
removing my discrete statement five
i'm going to put some new 10 new 11
these will be i instead of one i have
two discrete states
i know that from this discrete state i
can go to this one what happens from
this new
part of it i will i will deal with that
separately so that comes into the
refining the abstraction because you are
now looking into regions that are
smaller
subsets of the original regions
uh so let me show you a couple of some
examples so this is this is where we
want to take it and to some extent
the last decade of work has been able to
do it
so we're going to start with some
some abstract model of the system and
some specifications
and then go through this procedure come
up with some
code that we can implement on the system
and then push it to some simulation that
then see that it works or even better to
some hardware implementation
i have two examples here one this is a
quadrotor that we control these two are
not
we don't control them uh
so we want the controlled quadrotor to
visit
three points repeatedly uh in in the
future
roughly at those three points and we
obviously we don't want it to
crash into any other any of the controls
uh
uncontrolled the last two quadrotors in
the environment
we don't know what those uncontrolled
quadrotors will do
but we know that they will actually stay
uh within
uh one of them is gonna stay in that
line and the other one is gonna stay
in this line they will go back and forth
and these are physical objects if it is
here we know that in the next
instance it is not going to be able to
jump here so relatively mild assumptions
on what they can do and then
we essentially run this procedure that i
described
and come up with a a controller
layers of the controller for the
quadrotor that we can control and at
this point i cannot tell which one is
the one that we are controlling probably
this one is what we are controlling at
this point
okay so this is one example and the
other one is comes from a
student uh who worked on this as a
course project uh he works on humanoid
robots
and full body locomotion and there are
there are essentially cracks there's
there's first of all there's this
simulated body that this
robotic body that is trying to move uh
there might be
just slippage on the on this track there
might be cracks
let me go back and come back to it there
might be
cracks on the on the stairs it holds the
top part of it and there are cracks
there so it cannot hold at some point it
cannot fit there it needs to
it needs to slide so what multi
implement comes from the reactive
controller and how you implement that
within that mode comes from the
underlying continuous control
and uh and i gave i discussed only one
way of coming up with
a finite state abstraction that might be
useful for this hierarchical view
and there are obviously other ways many
other ways then we can discuss
uh throughout the throughout the program
now it's
simmons institute if you guys want
so here's another example and i will try
to finish this now
quickly uh traffic rules bunch of
assumptions on the behavior and the
mission
is in this two-lane road for this
vehicle
to visit these two stars infinitely
often so that's the high level goal and
there are a bunch of other rules that we
have
relatively naive dynamics but we have
limitations on the actuation and
disturbances on the
on the on what the vehicle does
so if we try to solve this problem just
a naive
discretization of the underlying
discontinued state space
not even the state space just the
position space here right just the
state spaces it might have its
velocities etc
let's look at this discretization of the
underlying positions
just this discretization is going to
give for us to deal with
attention eight seven states in the
reactive controller levels
yes reactive uh control synthesis has
seen
some progress but this is obviously
beyond what it can do
so when we faced with this we said hey
let's introduce
one more layer and it is its goal is it
it does the following
let's see how it behaves reactive
controller
uh takes care of when it isn't at the
intersection now
there's there's something intersection
it waits and then
there are the obstacles pop up when it
is a right turn it actually waited again
when there's an obstacle it changes its
uh
its course and it goes to the other lane
those are decisions that are being made
by the
by the reactive control there is this
top level
and the decisions the top level is
essentially making is
with respect to these even higher level
specifications
in the in this run the high top level
says go around this block
in that circular manner and then
obviously you will be satisfying
the visiting these two stars infinitely
often
and then at some point at this point now
uh there is there is a blockage that we
cannot do it anymore
and the top level now says okay you
cannot do it reactive controller said we
cannot continue here
and the top level now says okay now go
around this bigger block
in that circular manner still you will
be satisfied with these two coming to
these two stars infinitely often
so essentially the top level now the
third level is chopping the
uh the problem into small shorter
horizon constraints
the top levels has go around this and
that essentially maps it to a
partial order uh so that just instead of
trying to branch out we have a circular
path
we know how to proceed on that and it
helps us to
uh chop the problem into smaller horizon
problems that the reactive control has
to deal with it can crunch those things
quickly and then it tells which
lane to follow where to turn right left
weight etc
and then the continuous controller
implements those things
and extremely quickly what happens at
that top level is that
again we partition the discrete state
space
into different regions and uh the goal
is
to very pictorially and simply the goal
is reaching some target states the goal
state
and uh the relative uh configuration
with respect to that goal gives us a
order on the between these uh
sets uh this set is closer to the goal
this is closer to the goal etc
and then the reactive controller instead
of trying to solve this problem directly
it essentially starts instead of
starting from the ultimate initial
condition it starts from where the
system is
and instead of reaching the goal it just
tries to get to a
cell that is closer to the goal for
example starting from
w4 it is not trying to reach the goal it
is
uh it is just trying to for example
reach w2
because if you could do that we will be
able to actually from there proceed
toward the
uh toward the uh toward the goal and
it is receding horizon be partly
motivated by so-called recent horizon
control in
in the control literature because it
plans all the way up to w2
but when it comes to w3 on the way to w
tube
it says okay now let me redo it i am now
in w3
let me now draw my horizon and from w3
let me try to get to w1
and if the specification for the
middle level is set in this way
and there is this extra piece that we
called an
invariant uh then we can actually go and
uh talk about that this receiving
horizon implementation
of the short horizon strategies will
will be able to satisfy these
specifications is essentially chopping
the problem into pieces but then
for consistency again we need to have a
little bit more
in the in the problems that we have to
solve and we cannot just chop them into
pieces and hope that it's going to work
in order to be able to have consistent
evolution we need to have this
piece of invariant and invariant is
essentially
tries to come up figure out the
corner cases so called we don't want to
bring
in the solution of a problem we don't
want to bring the system to a
configuration from which the next system
cannot do anything
if it's sorry the next problem cannot do
anything if we try to solve the problem
in one shot
those things would have been excluded
by the reactive control synthesis
already but if you chop these things
into pieces for simplicity
then we we need to somehow figure out
how to
avoid those things and um so
this is the last slide uh so let me put
these things a little
comment on um that um
instead of now the the problem that
i motivated was obviously let me specify
something
and then use models to the extent that i
can and then synthesize
the controller so let's go from all
these models and specifications
to a control protocol for which i'm
going to have a grantee and i'm going to
refer to this as specifying synthesize
and a lot of work had been
um put into the the other side of the
coin which is designing and verifying
first design something maybe even build
it and then try to verify it it's going
to
behave safely but lots of examples of
hybrid physical systems and autonomous
systems
have shown that there is no limit to
human imagination
we can build arbitrarily we can design
and build arbitrarily complex systems
therefore first designing and trying to
verify is
may not be the way to go because it is
it might end up we might end up having
an
unsurmountable amount of complexity
whereas through specifying synthesis we
start with what we want and in each step
we keep track of uh the
some precise and unbe and ambiguous
specifications what can be done what
cannot be done
and then through that we can actually
one we can
we will have a formal and an unambiguous
way of expressing what is going on in
the system design and the second thing
is that we may be able to
suppress the complexity of the system
and it's going to also
uh be more suitable if i'm building up
a system uh rather than
trying to work with a system that is
given to me
i would have more flexibility to impose
architectural constraints
that will go and suppress the system
complex even further
for example we suppress the complexity
of the problem
by imposing this hierarchical structure
on the controllers
and is not the only way that we can
actually try to do this
there might be much modularity and
composable structures that we might look
into and compositional control synthesis
becomes very
important i don't think i'm going to
have time uh in these recorded lectures
but i'm happy to discuss those
motions as well and uh
and the biggest benefit from all these
things is
uh is essentially uh
starting from specifications having
formal specifications and trying to keep
track of that
and trying to have these approval
guarantees only
and products is uh we may or may not be
able to automate the entire design flow
we will probably not but it is going to
give us a discipline
or disciplined way of trying to deal
with this
unsurmountable amount of complexity
otherwise unsurmountable of complexity
if we do not have that rigor or if you
don't have
unambiguous specifications in each step
uh
it is just going to be a mess it's just
going to be a soup of a lot of things
that nobody can interpret
and uh so uh therefore i chose to talk
about specify
first specifying and then synthesizing
because i think that has
a much brighter future than trying to
deal with some other person's mess that
i can try to verify
so here i'm going to stop i'm happy to
discuss any of these things
to the extent that you want uh
thank you